it's not only that trump has to lose but
that all his enablers have to lose
they have to we have to collectively in
essence burn down the republican party
um we have to level them because if
there are survivors
if there are people who weather this
storm they will do it again
threats like these aren't only being
heard from rank and file liberals some
of the loudest voices are saying if you
don't get with the liberal program
good luck finding a job i truly
sympathize with those dealing with
losing
it's not easy but at a certain point one
has to think not only about what's best
for the nation
peaceful transfer of power but how any
future employers might see your
character defined during adversity
caitlyn collins just reported white
house staff are starting to look for
jobs
employers considering them should know
there are consequences for hiring anyone
who helped trump attack american values
find out how at the trump accountability
project the trump accountability project
mentioned there was just recently
founded
likely with the goal of naming and
shaming those who worked for trump's
administration so
they can't find any more work
congresswoman alexandria ocasio-cortez
also raised a lot of eyebrows with a
tweet singing a similar tune
is anyone archiving these trump seeker
fans for when they try to downplay or
deny their complicity in the future
i foresee decent probability of many
deleted tweets
writings photos in the future and who
could forget the mainstream media
trying to sabotage trump at every step
of his presidency is one thing but now
many want to prosecute him it's all very
different to the message of solidarity
in bringing the country together that we
heard in biden's victory speech
to make progress we have to stop
treating our opponents
as enemies there will be no blue states
and red states
when we win just the united states of
america
maybe his supporters got the wrong idea
because repressing red votes out of
existence
won't necessarily make them blue trump
supporters and conservatives have been
cancelled and banned and blacklisted and
defamed and
smeared relentlessly for the last four
years especially by mainstream media by
far left agitators people losing their
jobs for simply supporting the president
people uh having their homes docks
people being attacked trump supporters
are have been through all of this
they've survived the last four years
they're actually what i've been seeing
more emboldened
to get outspoken to stand up uh and
and to not be afraid of these tactics
anymore the democrats i believe a lot of
people believe do
tend to have they believe they have a
plan for a permanent democrat majority
in this country
so a republican could never get elected
uh in federal elections in this country
and uh uh and they can uh you know start
to march in their
their uh one party socialist
totalitarian utopia